[Musique]
ceci n'est pas une bouteille d'eau
c'est un exhausteur de goût qui va
transformer vos papilles
c'est un catalyseur
c'est ce qui nous offre peut-être
quelque chose de différent là ça y est
vous dites on est tombé sur un sommelier
complètement barré excentrique et ça va
pas être marrant mais en fait quand on y
réfléchit bien le vin
c'est de l'eau enfin du moins à 85%
maximum et oui
une eau végétale une eau qui est arrivée
d'abord par la plante puis ensuite par
le grain de raisin qui longtemps rôti
par un soleil à mûri et puis après il a
fini dans la bouteille donc comme on
rédige Jules Renard en parlant de Knokke
Jules Romain en parlant de Knock le
docteur Knock qui aurait pu dire tout
buveur de vin est à buveur d'eau qui
s'ignore
mais seulement
l'eau cette substance chimique
naturellement solvant à l'état liquide
de plus stable et très réactive nous
nourrit
inconditionnellement
et de façon indispensable pour notre
survie
si bien que comme
monsieur Jourdan faisait de la prose
sans le savoir nous buvons de l'eau sans
jamais la déguster
pourtant je peux vous assurer et je vais
essayer de vous le démontrer qu'on peut
aussi prendre du plaisir
en tant que sommelier
j'aime à penser que la dégustation c'est
d'abord la capacité de mettre des mots
sur des émotions
donc l'eau a pour moi une émotion toute
particulière car de temps en temps elle
m'aide à reprendre pied dans un monde
pas toujours facile
en plus
pour moi
l'eau m'offre une liberté dans mes
dégustations elle est ma compagne idéale
pour déguster des vins mais aussi pour
les repas en effet après avoir goûté
beaucoup de vin
et cracher aussi
j'ai besoin de faire un reset avoir un
palais propre clean puisque les 100
premiers vagues j'ai goûté vont être
suivi peut-être de 200 autres donc j'ai
besoin naturellement de leur offrir la
même chose de dégustation
au premier comme au dernier
et cet eau va m'offrir cette capacité à
justement nettoyer mon palais
c'est eau justement également on va
m'offrir une salive abondante agréable
qui va me permettre d'accueillir le vin
avec émotion
et donc naturellement de prendre encore
plus confiance en mon goût
bref vous l'aurez compris cette eau est
indispensable
le métier de sommelier ça n'est pas que
servir du vin ça n'est pas que servir
des apéritifs ça n'est pas que servir
des spiritueux le sommelier va s'occuper
de vous de A à Z de l'eau du café du thé
des infusions
et puis également des jus de fruits
et donc n'est-il pas naturel que lorsque
l'on parle d'un vin on puisse le décrire
avec beaucoup de mots avec une vraie
sensibilité alors que dès que l'on parle
d'eau on vous demande simplement si vous
voulez de l'eau plate ou de l'eau
pétillante
c'est mieux que la carafe ça rapportera
toujours un petit peu plus
mais en fait
quand on s'aperçoit que dans un
restaurant on a quelqu'un qui a la
capacité effectivement à mettre en
exergue l'eau et bien c'est une
spécialité qui est arrivée depuis
quelques années ça s'appelle l'eau Loli
et oui ça ne s'invente pas le paradoxe
avec le vin quand même présent
ils sont presque frères et sœurs
et donc l’onologie c'est cette capacité
à parler à évoquer à transcender une eau
pour la mettre en avant
et tout simplement par une dégustation
tout à fait classique
c'est-à-dire et bien c'est à dire qu'on
va goûter de l'eau comme on goûte le vin
et c'est logique on va utiliser tous nos
sens on va mettre tous nos sens en éveil
pour découvrir que cette eau bien sûr
on va commencer par la vue par l'oeil et
pour ne pas nager en eaux troubles il
faut les garder bien ouvert
naturellement il faut qu'on ait une eau
qui soit limpide qui soit brillante qui
soit chatouillante qui soit agréable à
regarder et puis en plus on va
développer notre nez et l'odorat une eau
peut être légèrement terreuse mais elle
peut être aussi fleurie florale elle
peut être saline elle peut être très
importante au niveau des arômes tout
comme complètement inexistante
le sens que l'on va utiliser peut-être
le moins au moment de la dégustation ça
va être Louis sauf si vous ouvrez une
bouteille d'eau pétillante et là vous
aurez ce léger frémissement qui va vous
prévenir effectivement que l'eau est
gazeuse et puis arrivera le toucher pas
le toucher de l'eau mais le toucher
tactile l'eau en bouche qui va vous
amener cette sensation une sensation sur
la richesse une sensation sur la
puissance ou bien une sensation sur la
sécheresse et oui une eau peut être
sèche
une sensation qui va vous donner bref un
goût particulier et qui va aussi vous
donner quelque chose de différent d'une
eau à une autre et puis arrivera
naturellement ce goût ce goût qui en
bouche va vous être agréable très
agréable ou pas agréable
de toute façon quoi qu'il en soit on a
besoin de consommer cette eau et quand
on la goutte suivant les sensations
qu'on va avoir qu'on va ressentir et que
l'on va générer on va avoir aussi des
sensations quand on prend l'habitude de
déguster de l'eau avec des graduations
quand vous goûtez une eau qui est très
riche en magnésium et bien en finale
elle a cette touche légèrement épicée
quand vous goûtez une eau qui est très
riche en calcium elle est toujours
légèrement un petit peu terreuse et
surtout presque de la rondeur et du
sucre quand vous goûtez une eau qui est
très riche en sodium et bien vous allez
avoir cette note iodée saline délicate
bref on pourrait presque faire des
accords si on osait
sur un plat pensé par un chef et puis
l'eau qui irait complètement en
adéquation avec ce plat qui vous
permettrait de découvrir en plus d'un
accord mais et vain un accord mais et
alors là je rêve c'est sûrement utopique
mais je pense que on pourrait
effectivement faire toutes ces choses là
on pourrait proposer et dans la
dégustation je peux vous assurer que si
on goûter les eaux d'une façon un petit
peu plus le mot n'est pas juste et je
m'en excuse respectueuse et bien on
comprendrait que si vous servez la même
eau
à deux températures différentes dans
deux verres différents si vous êtes
logique dans votre dégustation vous ne
trouverez pas le même goût parce que ce
serait deux produits complètement
différents
j'aime l'idée que l'eau soit quelque
chose de un vecteur agréable dans la
dégustation chaque eau est différente on
peut parler presque à notre terroir
parce que là où on est l'eau
elle n'est à un endroit qui lui est
unique quelquefois il va falloir des
heures pour l'attirer mais quelquefois
quand on est à notre robinet mais
quelquefois il nous faut des années pour
que l'eau arrive jusqu'à nous qu'elle
descende des montagnes qu'elles
descendent qu'elle arrive par des
sources et qu'elle nous offre
effectivement toutes ces voyages
gustatif qu'elle aura pris tout au long
des roches tout au long des goûts
qu'elle va accentuer avec le temps
chaque terroir va être différent chaque
territoire va être différent et chaque
eau est complètement différente à vous
de vous faire votre propre goût de ce
que vous aimez et de ce que vous avez
envie de découvrir
pour terminer mon propos j'aimerais vous
citer une citation médiévale que tout le
monde connaît
maître de l'eau dans son vin
alors effectivement mettre de l'eau dans
son vin si on prend le sens propre c'est
assez facile à comprendre
on a du vin on met dedans et puis en
plus pourquoi on faisait ça tout
simplement parce qu'à l'époque l'eau
était quasi à propre donc on avait quand
même plus de chance d'être malade en
buvant de l'eau quand buvendu vin par
contre pour ceux des altérer pour
s'enivrer un peu moins et surtout pour
que ce soit plus agréable voire potable
et bien on mettait effectivement
beaucoup d'eau dans le vin
ou plutôt beaucoup de vin dans l'eau
et puis rappelez-vous je ne vois pas vos
visages mais moi
et plein d'autres on a tout connu ça
chez mon grand-père j'avais le droit à
le dimanche dans mon verre d'eau à
quelques gouttes pour la teinter
légèrement qu'elle devienne au fil des
années de plus en plus rosâtres pour me
dire c'est le début de l'éducation de
ton goût mon petit on l'a tous fait
et quelque part on le refera
certainement un jour pour faire plaisir
à nos enfants à nos petits-enfants
mais si je prends le sens figuré de
mettre de l'eau dans son vin alors là
c'est complètement différent mettre de
l'eau dans son vin ça veut dire faire
abstraction de ces passions ça veut dire
modérer ces propos ça veut dire ne plus
être en adéquation avec ce que l'on aime
avec ce que l'on vit ça veut dire aussi
vivre une vie complètement
enclavée dans des conditions qui ne sont
pas les nôtres alors ça je peux vous
dire une chose et je vous le dis ici
avec aplomb
et avec une vraie certitude croyez-moi
c'est que moi je ne mettrai jamais d'eau
dans mon bras
[Applaudissements]